Jurassic world fallen Kingdom picks up  three years after the events of Jurassic  world the park is now of course closed  but the dinosaurs are left there to fend  for themselves  there is a dormant volcano that is going  to explode  Claire's character has put together a  group that get these answers and put  them somewhere safe and she recruits  Owen to come back because of his  relationship with blue I just saw them  I'm a commercial and I was so amazed  it's stunning there are so many  crystallizing images in this film that  are truly designed to be seen on an IMAX  screen  this film changes the equilibrium  between dinosaurs and humans  it's a massive film and it has a huge  scope which you'd want to experience an  IMAX I would love it I want to see that  bad you're missing out if you are not  watching Jurassic world falling Kingdom  on an IMAX  you  you